podcast special guest Malcolm Mays
uh you got new music out Sticks and
Stones yes sir uh for people who don't
know I didn't even know you made music
we got an interview that y'all can go
watch the separate where we dive into
all this but
I said if you're gonna pull up man I
gotta have you do your thing yeah you
made me like bro this I'm an RV [__]
you go make me rap all right this is
what you get all right hey glassy Malone
said you win last I said on me and saw
me if G Malone say you got to do it you
got to do it so we in this thing
definitely not true cause gene Malone
said some wild [__] to me that I decided
not to do over the years what was it oh
well he's crazy he's a crazy person yeah
but like I'm not saying everything but
he's a wild guy shout out to Gene Malone
very convicted let's get right to it man
Malcolm is in the building come on all
right [__] you God damn it
uh Kev only you can make me really rap
today all right come on man let's get it
then look I got some demons on my
FaceTime angels in my group chat I ain't
got no Ops though dead people don't
shoot back ain't saying I did it but if
we did we wouldn't do that man I'm on TV
I don't even do rap [__] had to rag
monks Fades have to shoot that [__]
know I'm verified I ain't paid for blue
checks sticks went boom back zero true
facts [__] that we beef with casket
soup Max and that's that I ain't trying
to glorify death care for real
I'm just saying that we survived me and
my [__] we just starting to live now
because a lot of us really ain't alive
so I don't do beef I mean we beyond it
and I only say sweets if the name of
mine in it Hotel baccarat I don't even
shoot craps [__] know I'm Basquiat
Street [__] that's that top of the tip
top time to go get guap yeah ninja Vinci
slides but I will never flip-flop solid
as a stone [__] Village is my home
[__] they treat me like Maximus
everywhere I roam [__] black Gladiator
black Russell Crow with it black chrome
Rose tinted they don't let the pose in
it they know there's the Bros in it they
know there's some hoes in it they know
if some does in it call me Mr go get oh
okay I'm not done though I'll keep going
man don't make me do it I'm gonna really
do it all right I'm gonna finish it R B
[__] rapping this is real stop playing
look
water on the Rollie but my timepiece
looking holy cause my grandma prayed for
me I'm the looking at anointing oil on
my Dome piece these [__] they know me
and my ex she really grow me so it's
probably matrimony black love is
mandatory believe me
streets they try to let me squeeze me
but really I could only be me I'm two
million up [__] and it's worth the
peasy
you gotta pay for anything else
and I might do it again because I need
it to be super clean but let me relax
come on hey I know you just watched a
new freestyle guess what we're dropping
them every week sometimes more than once
a week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week